Getting your daily exercise can feel like a chore, but with plenty of sun,...
...it's time to start taking advantage of popular activities only summer can offer.
Water sports like kayaking, canoeing, rafting and crew...
...are ideal for an upper body and core workout.
Rowing machines are great for cold weather,...
...but there's nothing like hitting the water to engage every muscle in the body.
Enjoy a solo adventure or invite friends to make it a group activity.
Explore one of the country's dozens of national parks...
...and hike your way into a smaller size.
Rugged terrain confuses your muscles and the spectacular views are always changing.
Make sure you wear supportive shoes and stay hydrated during your hike.
Swimming can be fun all year round,...
...but a swim in the ocean, a river or lake will really get the blood flowing.
Improve muscle tone and condition your body...
...without the bone-jarring effects some exercises have.
Rollerblading is a simple physical activity for all ages.
It works nearly every muscle group...
...and kicks your butt with cardio at the same time.
If you have the space, summer games like Frisbee, badminton or volleyball...
...are engaging for groups and offer a fun way to get fit.
Even a rigorous game of catch with the neighbors...
...is better than spending summer on the couch.
Being active every day can be a challenge,...
...but keeping your physical activities fresh make staying fit fun.
Find an activity you enjoy and make fitness a priority in your life.